hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
we're gonna check out the trailer today
and I told you Jerry
never watch trailers unless you're
coming over and the one time I was
binging trailers and he saw the trailer
for Everest but I haven't seen it yet no
you know we could just not tell them and
maybe my reaction would still be so
natural I don't like to lie to this
audience I have a huge [ __ ] well I mean
I saw it years ago
that's not huge well your shower is the
thing the grower know I grow did you're
you're more of a grower you're more of a
shower than a lot of people not when I'm
flossing are you sure I'm dead serious
I'm really insecure maybe you are like
half Kevin and then those are very
strange well yeah I was gonna yoga
intense peril and disturbing images like
fat chicks on a wire Hey in the very
footsteps of history something beyond
the power of words to describe given
beings simply aren't built to function
at the cruising altitude of a 747 our
bodies will be literally dying Everest
is another beast all together oh oh
Josh Brolin and Jason Clark how you
doing I'm back Doug Hansen what are you
doing on the island duck I deliver the
men first found that on hackers hope
stuff like that
sit down man climate eyes cheat chill
you know all these one day you me and
little Sarah little go climbing together
- today's a day huh
here
it hurts
it's dangerous why I have kids they see
a regular guy can follow impossible
dreams maybe they'll do the same
No
gonna take our we got let's go
tik-tok gee I didn't of course it's not
Maddox needs to be woohoo
dude look at that nipple chill nipple
chill can you guys see that it's a
nipple chill the trailer gave me the
chills I'm trying to say that was a
dense trailer man it's fine we just
watched the trailer for the walk and we
talked about Full Sail University I had
a similar feeling about that as I'm
having towards this cuz the deals you
know a lot with like Heights in a way
and also dealing with like overcoming
obstacles a lot of people are not
willing to do it's like it's one of
those things where the average person
might not really get it but you know
when you go on a journey with him like a
movie you tend to understand why this is
something important for them to do and
accomplish there is definitely that
component to this I feel there's one
thing that bugs me about this trailer
and it's Hollywood it out it's the storm
yeah it's like I feel like you have that
that looks like it's gonna be the first
half of the movie in the second half
because there's like I'm thinking
Hollywood movie yeah yeah it's like oh
what a perfect time it's like you know
there are movies where it's like and
versus the elements and extreme
conditions that don't feel like like the
grey for as yes punching Wolves as that
movie got pitched let movie is not
gimmicky like that and this movie I'm
afraid it might get gimmicky with like
oh the storms coming like it's not an
impossible thing but just something
about the way they show it in this
trailer makes it seem like oh ho now
it's got to be a disaster
like it says based on the incredible
true story but I was watching this going
I wonder how much of this is actually
true in terms of the disaster well yeah
I'd be interested to research it cuz it
would be really easy to be like well I
mean some dudes once climbed Everest in
a storm happened yeah zedd really
happened so now we're gonna take that as
a jumping off point you know that was
the my prom with the last half - because
it's like it could have been like an
adventure about going to Everest but
it's really about getting back the
getting back adventure probably happens
midway through yeah so when it happens
midway through the film and then it
here's the fall I started wondering like
where's the psychological aspect of this
film now like what happened to it it was
just it's just a [ __ ] trailer but
yeah the trailer was like going
Hollywood and [ __ ] like I started I can
hear that
as I was watching it well yeah it's like
the first half of this trailer filled
very like oh life II and and John Hawkes
is talking about like you know my kids
just see like an ordinary I deliver the
mail you know like I want to do
something extraordinary I think that's
really cool and then I just hope it
doesn't become well it's kinda like a
barmageddon' Hollywood you know and
that's the problem is like a lot of
Hollywood films look like big Hollywood
studio films will go let's establish
some character upfront and then let's
not focus on that anymore yeah I know
let's just get let's get to the fun
what's in the cell tickets but no I mean
jiggy cool I mean the cast looks great
like yeah and I chose our guys who seem
like they have a good judgment Jake
Gyllenhaal out of this whole cast Jake
Gyllenhaal tends most of the time to be
pretty selective about his films
especially nowadays
he seems very into disappearing you know
yeah and I feel like this is a
supporting character might get killed
off early I think that's why he was like
credited and Jake Gyllenhaal well you
never know I can't be sure when this is
film so maybe it was sort of in a
transitional period frame or something
and Josh Brolin he you know he tries his
best with picking pills he doesn't
always good he's always good that's the
thing about Josh Brolin is even when his
films suck you're like uh parole is
pretty cool in it but ever you know but
even even the the more character at like
John Hawkes isn't in everything you know
and he's really underrated look he's
great he's a great actor and I Keira
Knightley mm-hmm she's a woman now like
she's an adult you should remember
watching Pirates of the Caribbean and
jerking off to her when you got back no
no no there's something about Karen I've
never been super like haha so now I can
go with her when I watch Pirates both
her and Emma Watson both like those were
timing you know the times in your young
life and those two characters I'm like
yeah they're quite attractive they're
not like my favorite throwing young
Britney yeah yeah same thing for some
hmm
I'd be James Dean not the actor the porn
actor which is technically I think
anyway guys thanks for tuning into the
reject channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow Jerry's
playlist reasons to Jerry it's a fun
channel
what are we doing whatever it is so rich
up one channel we're just so random
youtubers love it arm and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where if we get enough followers we can
get product placement meaning more money
for us less benefits in your life except
for them oh please you're the production
values a little bit better
Oh have an actual like it's gonna go
towards the production value got one
from a lady who is quite cute she's a
cutie Jer she's a cutie
I don't know her name is Sarah Marshall
yeah might be guys yeah you know I'm
having a hard time telling if ya over 18
or under 18 so tread softly yes you are
attractive for the age that you are at
hey Ryan
saw your video last year sometime I
think it was either Carrie or some other
horror movie trailer reaction video
maybe it was in 2013
oh and tell Sally she's one of the most
adorable people I've seen she's just as
adorable as Chloe grace Moretz
I think Chloe grace Moretz is way more
adorable oh and by the way I like your
new haircut thanks Sarah maybe just grow
your beard out a little more them I
start calling you the American Mexican
Jesus haha it's my and bison laugh to be
the American Mexican Jesus oh you would
have to change your haircut - yeah I
know right
well the traditional depictions of Jews
didn't have like a buzz cut would you
rather see a sequel to Halloween
resurrection or a sequel to Freddy vs.
Jason I'd rather see a sequel to
Hollywood Direction starring Ryan Jerry
and Sarah nope no come on man we both
have girlfriends but they'd understand I
would rather see a sequel to Freddy vs.
why because like a I'm holy wood
erection no come on don't even call
Hollywood arrivals that have to do with
us cuz we're the erections
no more 9 then sounds like a horrible
doo-wop band
man and then afterwards we vine right in
the erections no no Matt baby
go wait wait wait wait wait wait wait at
the end of the movie we reckon we've
forget about Sarah Marshall whoa that's
what I did
hear that joke Freddy vs. Jason you say
that joke look at that joke anyway Sarah
Marshall is evil - yeah you stay pretty
that might get you far in life who knows
maybe intense only lasts here like 26 so
good luck to you you have bikini pics I
am closing my computer right now because
I'm committed